a new report warns Isis followers in the
Middle East may be plotting a chemical
attack on the United States the report
is based on intercepted conversations it
shows the desire by Isis to use chlorine
or other weapons of mass destruction on
American soil
US officials are working to disrupt the
plan a homeland security official said
quote the bottom line is the threat is
real CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell as a former
CIA deputy and acting director Michael
good morning morning how do you read
this new plot I think we should take
this seriously
Isis has for some time said that they
want to acquire weapons of mass
destruction and to use them and they've
actually been able to manufacture
chemical weapons in Iraq and Syria and
use them on the battlefield so this is
something we need to take seriously and
work to defeat and is it something we
need to take seriously because they can
bring it into the United States so they
might hit us targets overseas so it
seems the intelligence reporting is
about bringing it in I think we need to
be more worried about them making it
here this stuff is difficult to
transport it's difficult to get it by
customs and immigration I think it's
more likely that they send their recipe
here to their followers and they make it
here how easy is it to make it here on
bachelor's degree master's degree in
chemistry the right material is easy to
do how hard is it to deploy a chemical
weapon it's difficult to make it work
and spread widely right most people
think you need to spread it with
explosives but that actually deteriorate
some of the chemicals so it is it is
difficult to disseminate but again if
you know what you're doing and these
guys do then it can do real damage he
was traveling a lot of cages I thought
yesterday at one point he said the world
isn't listening to us but they're
listening to us now who was he talking
to Michael yes so now we're talking
about Vladimir Putin and and the speech
he gave right about nuclear weapons I
think he was talking to his own people
because he has an election coming up and
he wants to look tough the Russian
people like strong leaders an election
he's expected to win absolutely but with
more votes he's a good thing right he's
also he was also talking to us and he
was talking to us in two ways one is he
is deeply concerned
that our missile defense will degrade
his ability to use nuclear weapons to
strike us right and that's why he's
developing these exotic weapons that can
get around missile defense the other
thing that he was doing was talking to
us about North Korea when he said if you
attack us or our allies we will attack
you that was a message about North Korea
we now have the Chinese several months
ago saying that if you attack if you the
United States attack North Korea
preemptively we will fight on North
Korea's behalf now we have the Russians
joining that so there is this view that
the president is in such pals with
Vladimir Putin so if that were the case
why would Putin be saying things that
sound like they're coming straight out
of the Cold War because as I as I've
said before we are in a cold war again
without a doubt when you look at the
Russian invasion of Georgia the Russian
invasion of Ukraine the Russian
intervention in Syria the Russian
meddling in our election the attack just
last week by Russian mercenaries on US
troops in Syria we are in a cold war
again he understands that he's fighting
it we're slow to figuring that out yet
do we understand that the State
Department said there was no need to
increase sanctions because the Russians
are being deterred are the Russians
being deterred by US policy they're not
being deterred at all and every in US
intelligence official that's testified
before Congress in the last several
months has said exactly that isn't your
expectation that Admiral Mike Rogers was
testifying saying he doesn't have the
adequate authority to combat Russian
cyberattacks is it your expectation that
you will get that authority that we will
deploy more resources doesn't sound like
it to me and who was Vladimir Putin when
you look at him I - I used to be these
pictures of these steely blue cold eyes
staring back at me what can you tell us
a great question you know Bob Gates said
when you look in his eyes you see KGB
KGB KGB that's exactly right
he is a thug he is a bully he only
believes in relative power how much do
you have how much do I have right
bullies will continue to move forward in
the face of weakness they will stop when
they get punched in the nose we have not
punched him in the know he doesn't seem
to take the u.s. seriously does he you
know he does not know all right Michael
morale racing yeah yeah you gonna leave
us with that thank you very welcome